if you are looking for the latest and
best strategies for growing on instagram
making money and increasing your
engagement buckle your seatbelt because
in this deep dive training our guest
speaker today chalene johnson is going
to be breaking down tactical and
strategic
tips for growing your instagram and
making a greater impact and this is the
latest stuff you know there's been a lot
of changes on instagram so what's
working going into 2022
um you're going to learn that in this
video but one of the big topics we're
going to be talking about is earning
money and chalene has a lot of value
around
that but i actually just want to kick us
off with a power round right at the top
here and give you five ways i earn money
from instagram so you can jump start
your income with these tips the first
one is i earn money from instagram video
views you know what's been interesting
is instagram will pay you for video
views now in fact facebook owns
instagram and facebook inc sent me money
recently because of video views on my
videos too you can do affiliate
marketing and you can have a link in
your bio or you can use a link in your
stories and there's other ways to
integrate affiliate marketing to make
money on instagram three you can do
brand deals and sponsored posts i'm so
sure you've seen
ad on different posts brands will pay
you give you free product and integrate
with your content four you can do social
selling with direct messages whatever
your product service maybe you're
building a product or a service or maybe
you're a service provider of some kind
um business happens in the dms and
chalene is going to be going deeper into
really how to sell
on instagram in five you can invite
people into your sales process typically
that's a free download or a free class
or someone going to your website or
filling out a form to do business with
you to contact you or so to get on your
email list so you can follow up with
them with other things that you're doing
in your overall online business so
that's just five quick ways that i earn
money on instagram um and i want you to
get ready because today you're actually
being invited inside of what's called
our inner circle and so monthly we have
what's called our inner circle program
we're streaming this uh kind of a just a
bonus stream for you on our think media
podcast channel and so you're going to
kind of get to get to see some advanced
level content from chalene in just a
second um and then during the second
half of this um chalene is going to be
doing some q a and some hot seats with
myself and melissa on the think media
team after we get over the core training
so if you're fired up hit the like
button
if you want to drop your instagram
handle in the comments just do it with
the at in your handle not the link so it
doesn't get sent to spam and if you're
just meeting chalene johnson she's a new
york times best selling author she's
built and sold multiple million dollar
businesses she is an instagram
influencer one of the top named social
media experts when it comes to social
media in general she's the founder of
the marketing impact academy in
instaclubhub which i asked her to tell
you about a little bit later in case
you're saying man 2022 is my year to
crush it on instagram and she's an
all-time
human being when it comes to faith
family and a personal friend as well so
uh can we welcome chalene johnson today
shalene how's it going it's going really
good thanks for having me here sean i'm
excited man i'm so fired up to have you
back on you know we uh i've known you
for years now and besides your social
media influence in my life your business
influence i also am just so grateful for
really your mentorship in in business
overall and even just
living a smart life you've impacted me
in so many ways in terms of family and
my marriage uh in terms of health uh i
didn't even mention your you know uh
record holder of most fitness dvds
anybody know chalene in fitness programs
from piyo turbo jam
turbo kick chalene extreme oh my
goodness and the the 131 method and diet
man you've done so many different things
and so i'm just so grateful for you um
how you feeling today good you you know
i really appreciate you saying all those
things that was really nice too like
about family and faith and you did
forget to mention um my influence on
your playlist yeah i'm gonna let that
slide and we love to snowboard together
that's right and uh both passionate
about snowboarding well hey i'm super
fired up you've got a deck for us today
and so uh we're gonna get right into
your training and chalene johnson take
it away yeah okay well thank first of
all thank you everybody for having me um
i wanna just lay the groundwork first
and let you know that
uh what i'm going to cover is is
basically how to use
instagram to monetize it uh because i i
don't think that you're watching this
because you're trying to just be more
popular or be well known like there's an
end game to this so with that being said
that's specifically what i'm going to
share with you are things that will help
you to grow
and and to improve your ability to
monetize the instagram platform which is
a really really freaking
i don't want to say simple
because it's not simple but it is easy
once you figure out uh the strategies to
use
and so much of them are just common
sense when you think about human
behavior um but i love instagram i've
sold over four million dollars on
instagram just on instagram stories not
even on my feed just on instagram
stories and that's without paid
advertising now we do do paid
advertising as well but i wanted to
separate that so that you know that i've
earned over four million dollars just
using instagram stories organically but
there's a right way and a wrong way to
do that
and it's a lot right like instagram is a
beast instagram is trying to be youtube
it's trying to be a blog it's trying to
be
um uh twitter it's trying to be uh
snapchat it's trying to be um tic toc
it's trying to be like all it's not just
trying to be these all these things it
kind of is all these things
so there's a lot to learn there's a lot
of features etc in order for me to make
the best use of your time i'm just gonna
i have to go into this
on with the understanding that you have
a basic
level of competency with regard to
instagram i'm going to assume that you
already have set up your bio that you
understand some of the terminology
terminology and language that i'm going
to use but if you don't at the very end
we're going to do a q a so you can ask
your questions and as sean said i will
share with you at the end of my
presentation of some of these things
you're like but wait i don't understand
um how to figure out my niche or i don't
understand where to check my direct
messages we're going to give you guys an
opportunity to uh train with myself and
my son brock we kind of teach people
these basics so you don't have to become
a master at them but today i'm really
going to talk to you about how you can
use instagram to monetize whatever it is
that you want to monetize and just so
that you understand if you're not like
totally into instagram what i'm going to
share with you is completely applicable
to facebook uh to tick tock
um
really to just about any social media
platform even though we're going to be
talking about instagram but it's kind of
universal
and the first thing i want to share with
you is that instagram has changed so if
you haven't been on instagram if you're
new to instagram you are in like the
perfect position like it is harder to
get growth on an established account
than it is to get like rapid fire growth
on a new account so if you're newer if
you have under
say 300 followers um you're sitting
pretty
i'd love to see in the chat if i can how
many of you have under 10 000 followers
that would be great
under 10 000 followers so most people
have under 10 000 followers i mean
majority people do obviously if you're
watching this you're probably your
primary focus is youtube and i recommend
that all entrepreneurs have like a
presence on most platforms where people
can find you but it is also
i think advantageous to pick like one
platform and go all in but once you've
done that then you can kind of like set
it and forget it and then look at the
next social media platform and then just
continue to grow your reach and so for
those of you are interested in doing
that in instagram couple things i want
to share with you that have changed in
the last two years
that i think you're going to find to be
really refreshing
number one um instagram
content used to be like about these
beautiful curated lives and like a feed
where everything looked beautiful and
and it matched your brand and your brand
logo was there and you picked like a
color scheme and and you saw like little
dashes of pink and all of your posts and
everything was like perfect and you were
trying to show this like perfect life
that makes people gag now it just it's
not interesting it's not valuable it's
not believable it's not authentic and it
doesn't work so the only people you see
doing that we'll actually see a lot of
people still doing it but not very i
don't know anyone who's doing it and
it's actually helping them to grow
what works today
is
understanding that your audience has
very little time
and we're already all of us feel like
we're using social media way too much
we're at this tipping point where we're
like we hate social media and we love it
but we all know we need to spend less
time on it so nobody's following
accounts just to see like what your kid
is doing today or what you had for lunch
or that you went out to dinner with your
best friend from high school nobody
cares
like it's news flash
because we don't have time to like we
used to when it first started like we
loved looking at like oh well look at
this person they're on vacation that
looks so fun but
today unless you already listen closely
the people who can still do that are
people who are have reached the tipping
point like they're already beyond
sheehan's wall
meaning they're already well known
they're already established in their
niche and now they can talk about all
the things but today if you want to
crush it on instagram
much in the same way you want a crush on
youtube you need to niche
down to a place like so niche that it
feels uncomfortable
and then you need to produce content
that's incredibly valuable and here's a
word that i want everybody to type so
that you don't forget it shareable
content
if you're not producing content that
other people want to share you're not
going to grow
because the only people are going to see
your content are the people already
following you
you're not going to be found on the
explore page you're not going to be
found with hashtags you just ain't going
to be found
unless
the people who are already following you
share what you've posted and now
it's like they're promoting you
to all of their followers that's how you
grow shareable content so if i posted a
picture of myself out to dinner with my
arm around sean
we both look great
hashtag no filter are you going to share
that post
no
because why would you like it's it
doesn't it doesn't serve your followers
so why would you share it but if i
shared something that was really in
alignment with like what like you're
like oh man you just rip the words right
out of my mouth like that's exactly what
i wanted to say about this so that was
so freaking funny
i am dying laughing you're probably
going to share that because we share
content that reflects well on us
right so that's how you grow and there's
a lot of other ways to grow but i just
want to give you those quick tips
because i think that's really important
because if if we're gonna if we're gonna
sell we need more people following us
but let's talk about what people think
it takes to sell on instagram they think
that you need a big following they think
that you just post up a link or you use
a link sticker you put a link in your
bio and then you just like you know
count that money honey but that is
absolutely false it's not how it works
um
for the most part you know that it's
there's more to it the first thing you
have to do though is figure out like
what the heck are you going to monetize
and the good news is as sean mentioned
in my intro
there's a million things you can
monetize you can monetize your influence
you can monetize expertise you can
monetize your opinion um products
digital products physical products and
of course services so here's some
examples of some students of ours who
are monetizing uh a variety of things so
influence you know natalie jill is an
expert who
people know her for her ability to help
people lose weight specifically fat loss
and so she has got such credibility and
influencer that just about anything that
she talks about people are like i want i
want the i want to buy that i want to
buy that peanut butter so she can
everything that she uses in her life she
can create an affiliate link for it and
every time she talks about it
every time she talks just sharing her
life because she's got such influence
she's monetizing um this is richard
gonzalez one of our students who his
expertise is dog training so he can
monetize that on social media i love
this gal melinda farina this is somebody
i just recently had on my podcast what
she monetizes is her opinion
on plastic surgeons
she's not paid by the plastic surgeons
she is paid by consultations and she's
it's just her opinion but she's getting
paid for it physical products these are
uh two additional students of ours rob
and melissa and they
take uh they go on these flea market and
like you know um uh thrift shopping and
then they resell and repurpose and make
a huge
handsome living selling physical
products
this is kim garcia you guys might know
kim she's awesome
and she uses instagram to sell her
digital programs
this is shan she uses ig to promote her
services she's a copywriter
and then um tulin tulin is great because
two
and a lot of these gals and guys um
monetize all of these things but
and once you figure that out like once
you figure out how to to monetize all of
these things now every single time
you're on instagram you're making money
now you are making money right it might
not be a lot on every single post it
might not even be your intention
but if you've got that kind of influence
and people trust you you literally can
monetize all of those things but i want
to start by um and this is this is
really important what i'm going to go
over right now because if you understand
this you're going to understand why
sometimes you're doing everything right
and you're like i don't get it i'm not
selling like
people are not buying from me why like i
know
this product the service this thing that
i have
can change like every i want to shake
everybody because they need it but
they're not buying let's figure out if
one of these things is not obvious to
your followers so these are the top
reasons why
people buy so number one is they buy
because they want to save time number
two is they want to save time or money
or make money uh number three is because
they want to avoid some kind of pain or
loss
right now that's not always physical
pain like it might be like oh i need to
sign up for
um the think media's next launch because
i don't want to lose out on that
opportunity people buy because they want
to transform themselves or transform
their lives or improve who they are and
ultimately a lot of things that we buy
are just because we think it's going to
make us feel good
right
so if you think about um and and these
are some of the easiest things to sell
so if you have a product that just makes
people feel good makeup
clothing
um massage services like things that
just make people feel good
those are often impulse buys and you
don't need as much
of a runway
in order because that that's sometimes
people just like i just want to feel
good and they'll buy
but even if you have even if your
product your service whatever it is
you're offering your influence
is giving people all five of those
things if you don't already have
trust established it's gonna be really
tough to buy and it's gonna be really
tough to sell and the thing that i
always like to say is um
i don't sell on instagram i don't sell
on instagram i explain
i am not interested in selling i feel
like selling is what we do when we try
to convince someone to buy something
that they don't need and i don't want
that i want because because of this word
trust
if i lose my trust i'm done
so even though i might be doing
something completely different
five or ten years from now
it i'll still be
very successful financially because i
will always
be certain that i never lose people's
trust and that means i've got to be
honest
it means i've got to be authentic it
means i i can't promote things i don't
really like
it means i can't be quote obsessed with
everything i show that is my absolute
pet peeve those influencers no one's
going to be talking about them
three years from now the people are like
oh my god you guys okay i'm obsessed i'm
literally obsessed okay this you guys
i'm so obsessed like no you're not you
you're not obsessed you're you're
sharing a link and that's why you're
obsessed you know what i mean and that
that's how you
slowly erode trust is by not being
authentic not being real and we're not
going to do that and there is a formula
for trust that i want to share with you
and it's pretty simple this is a great
book i highly recommend it if you
haven't already picked it up i listen to
it probably once a year on audible it's
called the trusted advisor and this is
really important because trust is like
like i said it's kind of everything
but your trustworthiness is can boil
down to a an equation so people look at
credibility
how reliable you are
plus the intimacy like how how close are
we and that can be like i'm just seeing
your stories on a regular basis it can
be frequency
so if you're only posting to instagram
once a week that i that intimacy is
going to be missing
and all of that
is divided by the s the s stands for
self-orientation
so our audiences are always looking at
us and say and we're we don't even
realize we're doing this you guys but we
do we're like
is this person like are they really
trying to help me
or are they is this for them like are
they promoting themselves is this all
about self-promotion
and we all follow people like that we
are like
you know i don't know it's hard it's
hard for me to describe an example of
that without feeling like i'm calling
out somebody do you know what i mean but
like there's so many people that i'm
like
good for you do you know what i mean
where you're just like oh great i don't
know there's just certain accounts i
hate to say this but i honestly there
are certain accounts that i um follow
just because they annoy me
i just need to unfollow those accounts
but those are the people because it's
like ah you're so like this is just all
about you this isn't about your
followers you're not like you're not
interested in what's a good use of my
time
um this equation credibility is how
people perceive you reliabilities can we
count on you for this intimacy is that
emotional connectedness but when you
think about social media i want you to
think about um the emotional
connectedness of the content that you're
creating and the conversations that
you're having and then
self-orientation is pretty obvious it's
just that people perceive
um that you are about you
okay so how do we
sell on instagram
okay let's take this slide down for just
a second because what i'm going to say
is really really important for you to
understand and to remember
okay
it's this
the place that you're going to monetize
is in your stories
it's in your stories
there's one exception right now could
change but that one exception right now
is reals
but for the most part if you try to do a
promotion or a sale or a click the link
in my bio to buy blah blah to your feed
post
it will tank
i'd love for someone to prove me wrong
but it will tank unless it's a real
we'll talk about that in just a moment
so
your feed and i want you to summarize
what i'm about to say your feed is where
you attract new people
your stories is where you go deep build
the relationship and ultimately sell got
that feed is where we attract people
stories is where
you can really go deep with people your
feed needs to be very niche
it needs to be very niched
your stories can be all over the place
as long as there's value
because it's in stories where we want to
know who's behind this brand who's
behind this account the link sticker if
you don't already have it it should be
coming to you soon
no longer do you have to do a 10 000
followers to get the swipe up uh you can
use a sticker
on instagram stories and paste the link
to wherever it is you want to sell
people
or send people i should say but keep
this in mind
um are you seeing my slides right now
yes there we go okay so you just click
on the sticker
button and again if you don't understand
how how to do these things we'll give
you an opportunity at the end of this
broadcast uh where i can i can share
with you how i can teach you these
things but you just click on the the
sticker
link right there and you can select the
sticker link if you've already got that
that allows you to then paste up your
link but i don't recommend it
i don't recommend using that and i'll
explain why in just a moment but here's
a legitimate stat on one of my recent
posts my average story replies meaning
someone asking me about it
uh i know almost 2 000 and then people
who actually clicked on the link
was
under 800. so double the amount of
people replying to the story asking me
for the link
versus people just clicking on the link
now why is this important i'll show
share with you why because replies
mean conversions people are 76 percent
more likely to buy from someone who
they've had a conversation with
write down that stat 76 percent more
likely to buy from someone who they've
actually had a conversation with those
conversations mean you're building a
relationship
and those relationships build trust and
that trust means you can monetize your
influence your expertise
your
services your products all of those
things and trust as we know makes sales
something that's not uncomfortable it's
very natural it makes things easier for
people okay and the other reason why i
replies are so important is because as
jim rohn says
the fortune is in your follow-up if i
send you to a link
i have no idea if you went there or not
i've no way of knowing i have no way of
following up and saying hey i was just
checking back to see if you jumped on
that webinar what did you think or do
you need any suggestions i saw that you
were trying to pick out camera equipment
is there anything i could you don't know
that you even had somebody who might
have questions you'd have no idea but if
there's a conversation you can flag
those comments you can follow up with
additional questions you can have a
conversation and that's a relationship
so let's talk about what the social
media buyers journey looks like
specifically on instagram but this is
pretty true for most
social platforms
versus your feed post right like that's
the content that people when i see a
great post of yours
right and i'm like this is funny and
it's about adhd and i have adhd so i
wonder if they have other funny content
about adhd and then i go to your page
and it's like what you have for lunch
and it's like a cute picture of your dog
and this you know your last vacation
post and and that adhd post was just a
random i'm not following you
because i'm looking for funny adhd
content right but if i go to your feed
post and i see what i'm looking for
i found you now i'm going to follow you
and i'm probably going to look at your
bio to see
who it is you are and what type of
content you're going to be posting and
that's ultimately how we decide if we're
going to follow someone and then after
i've been following you for a little
while there's gonna this happens to all
of us there's a point in which you're
like
oh who's behind this account and then
you look at stories
and it's in stories that we figure out
whether we like someone
if we relate to them and that's why it's
okay and stories to be off niche
that's where you can show your kids your
dog your food your politics if you want
i mean if if you want um
you can show who you are because that's
where we create remember the i that
emotional that that intimacy that
intimate connection happens in stories
so
uh bonus tip
you need to be posting to your stories
all the time and when i say all the time
just document your day
here's how i remember when to post my
stories if i think i do you guys talk to
yourself do you ever talk to yourself
whenever i catch myself talking to
myself i always think oh i should just
say this on instagram or whenever i find
myself like with a huh i wonder if
anyone thinks this i just i just show it
on instagram whatever i'm doing that day
i just it's 15 seconds it takes no time
and you don't even have to be on camera
it can just be your words it can be a
poll but the key to great story content
to make sure that your bubble shows up
at the front of the pack
is to have it be an interaction a
conversation not a monologue but a
dialogue so how was your day
um tell me what you're struggling with
uh you're asking questions so it's
really important that you're using
instagram stories even if you have even
if you have like 30 followers and it
feels like it's crickets it feels like
it's crickets because there isn't that
intimate you don't need a lot of
followers to have a lot of sales but you
do need an intimate connection and that
intimate connection happens on stories
and the and the messier it is the better
believe it or not all right so is that
helpful let me know in the comments if
that's helpful for you to understand it
can be really messy in fact it shouldn't
be curated it should feel it should feel
hella real
very real on your stories
i know you guys follow sean cannell on
his instagram stories but i have to say
like his stories are on point
they're so good
they're great
okay people are telling me that they do
post often but maybe not enough all
right good and then ultimately if once
people are having conversations with you
those direct messages that builds trust
that is a huge way to build trust
especially if you're not coming like
right out of the gate and trying to sell
people something which is super annoying
um and then ultimately once you've got
that trust you don't have to sell to
people people already trust you so when
there's something that you love and
enjoy and you just explain it people
will buy from you
so would you like to see some examples
of what this can actually look like can
i show you my specific templates these
are templates now
someone's going to ask me how often do
you post these kinds of templates how
often are you selling on instagram
here's my answer
i'm never selling
i'm never selling but i'm one of those
people as i'm sure many of you are who i
can't help but talk about things i
freaking love
i can't help it i can't help but be in
line at the grocery store and if i hear
the checker talking about um her blender
i can't help but tell her excuse me
i know it's expensive but you need to
buy yourself a vitamix it's a very
expensive blender but you'll never buy
another one i'm telling you you've gotta
like i can't help it if i think it's
gonna make your life better i'm gonna
tell you about it and so because i am
constantly talking about things that
make my life better or i want to help
improve people's lives i guess you could
say i am always
using my influence
and if there's an affiliate code linked
to that great but i'm always trying to
help people always but there are
specific times where it's like okay i
have an objective
and the objective today is to make sure
that i explain to people what it is i
want them to buy i'm not going to sell
them but i'm going to explain it to
people and i want to share with you a
couple of templates that you can copy as
is the first one i call the fomo
template all right so this is one that i
used recently on the i did an instagram
bootcamp with my son
and this is a fomo so fear of missing
out right so the first thing i'm going
to post and each one of these is a post
this is just a 15 second post so the
first one is just a a static image
that's it's about hype right so i'm just
talking about the fact that we had over
4 000 people register or who attended
that day
um the next one might be like a recap so
this is just the next slide right and
the next slide is just some of the
things that we covered
and i'm intentionally trying to make
people who weren't there go like
i i need this like i'm helping them
reach that decision i'm not telling them
that they need i'm helping them like
read through and go like maybe they're
going gonna go i already know how to do
all these things well then then i don't
need to sell them i've explained it to
them
then the next thing i'll do is have a
conversation right so i'm this is a
it's got two benefits to it the first of
which is i'm having a conversa a
dialogue right so it's not a monologue
and the second
the second reason why this works is
because it also creates social proof for
me so i'll say so would you learn after
day one then my next post is going to be
responses
and i'm just posting up some of the and
people are going to read this and go
like oh man i missed all that on day one
and then the fifth one and this is
really important when it comes to sales
is urgency so it needs to be really
really simple and for me what i did is
rather than send doing a swipe up i'm
not going to do that
rather than using a sticker link which i
could have
or sending people to the link in my bio
which i could have i'm going to make it
easier for them
and i'm going to create a conversation
so i just say
send me the word
bootcamp
now automatically people are like oh
this is great
i'm actually going to have a
conversation
so if they send me the word bootcamp and
now i have it automated using a program
called manychat i'm not affiliated but
y'all
who
whoo if you don't have a lot of time for
instagram y'all need to get on that
manychat like it is amazing m-a-n-y
man many people make it sound like i
said mini mini manny manny m-a-n-y
manychat you're probably familiar with
it on facebook but now it's an instagram
approved partner so you won't get dinged
for it and you can set it up to automate
responses so when people send me the
word um bootcamp i send them an
automated response and questions and the
link in their dms it's amazing
okay and we'll talk about that you guys
can ask some questions about manychat
but it's free to begin with i think it's
tiered like you know once you have a
certain amount of followers it goes up
but it's worth every freaking penny i
freaking love it okay i don't use it on
everything but i use it you'll see okay
here's an example this is an example of
how you can use a feed post
to do that same thing and to get people
to i'm not selling them but what i am
going to do is i'm going to create
curiosity and that this is what works in
the feed post so for those of you who
have tons of youtube content remember
this word please write it in the
comments
create
curiosity
because if you lay out everything
no one's going to go and watch your
youtube video
but if you put up a snippet
of like the latest video that you just
dropped and like a good producer on a
television show who knows the
cliffhanger to leave people off on where
you're like well wait what what did he
slap who slapped her who was it that
slapped her oh my gosh we have to wait
through the commercials to find out who
slapped her right like you want to leave
some curiosity or you're like well what
was that who makes that all of these
things right so leave the best part of
your snippet to create a one-minute
video
chop up your latest youtube video create
a one-minute video that doesn't give
people the information they're really
looking for it just makes them super
curious
and then you can use this automated
program like manychat or you can just do
it manually and say if you want
um the link to my latest youtube video
to get the full
story
just drop the comment youtube below and
i'll dm you
don't make people go to your link they
won't
half the people won't
most people are more likely to leave you
a comment that does a couple things
number one
conversation
right number one conversation number two
engagement that's huge on instagram
engagement is huge
number three we're building trust when i
send someone to a link i'm not building
anything except to say that like i don't
have time for you okay so watch this
reel and i'm not sure if this will play
for us we will try
[Music]
is
i can feel the vibe but we just have the
audio for your speakers and not quite
but it was still we
we felt it
okay so check this out
340 000 people reached
more information okay so check this out
so oh i you couldn't hear the music but
it was a great song um and that's all i
did that was a bottle of organic wine
and you guys probably noticed that the
words went by too fast and you couldn't
read them
type in the comments below if the words
went by too fast and you couldn't even
read
everything that i'd written about the
wine
yes
yes okay
that's intentional
because if you're interested you're
going to watch that video again
and again until you've read everything
that's intentional
and then when people watch it again that
boosts
the algorithm
now instagram is saying like what's
going on with this video people are
watching it multiple multiple times
yeah
and the more people watch it the more
intrigued they are and now you're
thinking yourself i just i've just
freaking spent
four minutes watching the same 15 second
video uh i'm invested
i want to know and so i said to people
in that reel
comment wine below and i'll send you the
link and you can see on the screen here
i've almost 4 000 people
request that link
4 000 people it was a huge month for us
and now i'm an affiliate for dry farm
wines but it's like something i'm just
like it's just a wine i like it's like
not ever been like a big you know
source of our income it's just a wine i
like and i talk about it so i signed up
to become an affiliate why not um i
believe in it and uh but this month was
our biggest
month ever and number one
ladies you're gonna understand this um i
didn't have to put hair and makeup on
you know what i'm saying like some days
you're like i just i can't i'm not i
can't go on camera i'm not in a camera
ready kind of mood and i'm not in a
camera ready state uh all i did is i
took my camera as you guys saw i just
took my phone and i went
you know like this on a bottle of wine
and i added a trending song behind it
and some comments
so oh you did hear the music i bet yeah
i bet you heard it through my mic
people said oh i've fallen for that yeah
okay so that's how you can do it on
instagram i'm sorry on reels that's to
your feed but remember
again
there's a conversation happening so i've
moved people from my feed to my direct
messages and that's where trust is built
right
this is good is this working for you
okay good um can i forward this
now my screen is not allowing me my uh
i can't afford the slides
let's see why would that be
hey sean do you know why i can't avoid
the slides
i don't know but this is fire and people
are saying this is it's so clever
because i i think about that i reels
doesn't let you press and hold like
stories does so i'm like ah i got to
watch it again yeah oh i got to watch it
again
um and so when you realize you've
invested time and you're like well i'm
in vet like now i'm really invested
yep and i got to catch it all so super
uh grateful great tips hit like if
you're getting value what's your aha
moment so far i don't know if you want
to try to
i don't know how to get it going but um
you could try to like are you able to
afford it for me oh wait now you're
there now oh yeah
okay cool so i've set it up with an
automated response um again you can do
this manually so if you don't have a lot
of followers and you're thinking like
i'm not going to get 4 000 requests
maybe i'm going to get 20 then just you
can just automate this i'm sorry you
don't you can do it manually and you can
just do a copy and paste or you can use
a text replacement which is a feature on
both the iphone and the android where
you can type in maybe a three letter
code and that populates a longer reply
but i like setting these up as
conversations uh and manychat allows you
to set up flows where i can ask a
question
right like so do you like red or white
like you know and then the person says
oh i love white me too i'm obsessed with
sparkling wine i just found taste so
bomb here's the link
right so you can just set up so there's
actually a conversation and people
really love that
um okay so let me share with you my next
template okay the first template was
called the fomo
this template i would call unboxing
right and i'm probably going to do this
later today if you're following me on
instagram follow me at shalene johnson
and i'll share with you another i'll do
an unboxing today
because we just released new push
journals a physical product and i'll
show you how i do this but here's an
example of one that i did
uh for lipstick so i started off with a
pull sticker and this is really really
important so that's number one and at
the end of the slide i'll let you guys
take a screenshot of it because you're
gonna steal these templates they
freaking work i'm telling you we've got
10 000 members now in our instagram
insta club hub and we pull them
constantly to figure out what's working
what's not working a lot of these
templates i've gotten from our members
because they work okay so this is called
the unboxing the first thing you want to
do is set up a poll sticker because the
poll sticker has people self-identify as
yes i have this problem
so for example sean might post up on his
stories to promote this training today
are you struggling to
sell anything using instagram are you
making money on instagram yes or no and
if people type um no i'm not well then
now they're already they've raised their
hands that i'm interested in whatever it
is you're going to be talking about next
and that's kind of huge and then the
next thing is i i just share a little
bit direct to camera that's what dtc
stands for direct to camera i'm talking
about in this particular example how i
hate
trying to buy new lips lip color
guys can't even relate to this but like
ladies it's like you can't really try on
lip colors you can put them on your arm
but it's like not the same so i talked
about how i've wasted so much money
trying to buy the right lip color so i'm
just sharing my own story i'm relating
to it then i open up the product and
this is where you're showing people
exactly what it is you're talking about
so i i'm revealing the solution if you
will right so for an example with uh
using sean again would be like first the
poll sticker are you struggling to grow
on instagram then direct to camera him
saying yeah you know for me i'm so
focused on youtube it was like really
kind of hard to wrap my head around how
to use these micro videos to drive
traffic to my youtube channel and so now
he's that direct-to-camera relationship
and then the unboxing or the reveal for
him might be that he's sharing um a
screenshot of this live training
or he's sharing a screenshot perhaps of
how much his instagram has grown and you
can show the growth pattern so it's just
a reveal of the solution if you will
so here we go you guys probably can't
hear this but
the whole thing in the camera
but then let me show you the colors okay
so these are the glosses
little mini glosses
yes so the key here is you don't rush i
think people try to rush
through an unboxing or a reveal and you
don't need to because i want to feel
as the viewer
is if i'm there
and i can control
what we're looking at
so imagine what it was like the first
time you
either looked online at this digital
product or the first time you were
taking apart this camera or the first
time you were opening up this box of
makeup like take your time and showing
people
what it is that they're getting
and then the next
post is just a static photo with a poll
remember because we always want to
include people
so that it is a dialogue and not a
monologue and then the last one is a
poll sticker just saying like okay so
that insane box of lipsticks
was 40
that's insane
so then my call to action is like hey if
you want the link just click the lips
and i'll send you the link it's it's
like it's a special for them
and i'm not um
uh i don't work for this company but i
do have an affiliate link and so not
only is it cheap 40 bucks like plus if
you use this the link i'm about to send
you you get another discount which is
insane and i can't it's a promo so i
don't think it's going to last for long
and then everyone who clicks on the lips
with that story all i do then is wait
for people to respond and then you swipe
up on the story and get this instagram
will show you
the instagram handles of people who said
yes i want it and the people said no i
don't need it
right and then you can automatically
even if those people aren't following
you even if you're not following them
you just tap on whatever people you want
to send the link to
and you can send them a pre-populated
message or you can type it individually
you just click on the little arrow
button right and that sends them a
direct message
and that's really really powerful now i
can follow back up and say like hey did
you did you get the lipstick you know or
whatever what did what did you think but
it's so much more effective than sending
people to the link in your bio or or to
even
using the link sticker i mean i usually
you'll see on my story sometimes i use a
link sticker it's just because i'm being
lazy
but if i really want to convert
i definitely use this um so my amber's
question is what tool do you use to get
that overhead angle what overhead angle
i'm not sure oh oh oh gotcha yeah it was
just a tripod i just said a tripod that
like i could tilt over it or or you know
what i probably just had my husband hold
it like half the times i can't find my
tripods or they're broken
okay so there uh we'll skip over that
one because we saw this one oh
okay so this is this is another example
of the type of content i want you to
create
for your reels
number one use a trending sound
number two quick cuts you you already
know all about that but i mean
every one second to two seconds there
should be a transition
and number three and this is the biggest
create curiosity
make people watch it and say
i'm confused
where did you get that make people watch
and say wait a second what was that
make people watch and say
i need that where do i get it what's the
name of it when you tell people where to
get it what the name of it is how much
it costs
um and and why you bought it and the
name of the company etc there's no
conversation
people are on about their merry way you
must create curiosity it is a
cornerstone
of good marketing so here are some
examples of people who've created reels
who've really
really understand this concept i'm going
to move my microphone closer to my uh
desktop so you can hear the music okay
[Music]
pow
it is so easy to transform yourself
every day you know i love
transformations
what will she come up with today let me
think let me think wait a minute and
boom here you go got on my nice little
hair i fluffed it up i have like a fair
faucet looking girl today
hey 58 looks pretty good
when i'm feeling sad i simply remember
my favorite things
[Music]
nice okay so did any
let's talk about what we saw in these
videos like so there's a lot of
curiosity right so for example that one
with where they're like pouring
cocktails
i personally
probably watched that video
40 times
and and after like the probably the 30th
time of watching i'm like what am i even
watching like
first of all now i'm dying for a
cocktail but i kept watching it and then
i stopped i'm like now why did i watch
that so many times
and it has a couple of elements i just
want to bring to your attention the
first of which is
they kept spilling like they're letting
things just like pour over i'm like
who's gonna clean this up like my ocd
was like on fire so that made me watch
it a million times and then i was i just
had so many questions after i watched
i'm like so is that one
champagne and they just mixed it with
things like i literally watched it so
many times because i had so many
unanswered questions that i kept
thinking i was going to get from the
video but i i didn't i just realized the
video left me curious
the woman who was like um what is she
gonna do today and then she's like
look at me and she's like and you're
like
wait
is that the same person
i have so many questions like did you
have a facelift like
is this like is this a filter like i
have so many questions
questions create curiosity curiosity
creates conversions those conversions
those conversations that is what builds
intimacy and trust and then we don't
have to struggle with sell sales because
now
we're
we are um
we're in a relationship and so now i'm
gonna save you time because you already
trust me because i'm not gonna lead you
down i'm not gonna lead you astray i'm
never gonna sell you something i'm going
to explain things to you so you have
enough information to figure out if it
works for you or not
and you trust me for that and that's
really important here's another really
simple example i'm just curious in the
comments let me know if any of you have
a physical product that feels like it's
hard to explain
or it needs a detailed explanation of
how it works so let me know in the
comments if that is you
because if it is
awesome
that works beautifully with curiosity
the fact that people don't fully
understand it
is magic
because now people have to ask questions
here's an example and let me just show
you
what this is this when i saw this i was
like oh my god
this is so brilliant okay watch
i want to play that again can
i go
[Music]
well let me just say
immediately i had to buy one like i'm
like i don't i don't even know what i'm
gonna put in it but like i have to have
one
i mean i had a lot of questions when i
watched this video and you know what it
did it made me go and follow her
and uh become like such a fan she she
invented these it's a great story she
invented these um four years ago just
using a piece of paper and like folding
it up it's this young girl who's in la
and that video
is so fast and so easy it's called a
splay
it's called a splay tray
and it just opens up and it displays
everything on a tray and then bloop it
closes back up i'm like i just i have to
have it in every color like i love it
um but the key here is that she pro i've
watched some of her earlier videos and
in her earlier earlier videos she really
goes into this long explanation etc i'm
bored
she answered all my questions like i i
wanted this video made me watch it a
million times and then it made me go and
look at all of her other content to
understand it like this created
curiosity and then have a conversation
with her and then ultimately become a
trusted customer
so really cool if you've got a physical
product that you feel like it needs a
lot of um explanation perfect don't
explain it leave people wondering leave
people with questions now you have to
understand that this only works
if you're making certain that these
things are in place or in other words
this won't work
if you haven't made it really clear to
your audience what problem they
have right so for example if i can share
with you that last in this particular
case
um
i didn't know
she has she this video kind of makes it
clear to me that i actually need every
my makeup laid out
i didn't realize the problem with my
makeup bag is it's in one giant bag and
i have to dig through it to find things
her video makes it makes a problem very
obvious to me that i didn't even realize
i had
that i need things displayed
so if you're not helping your customers
understand what the problem is you're
not going to sell you're also not going
to be
instagram facebook youtube tick tock
none of the you're not going to sell if
you've got the wrong people following
you or if it's the wrong offer
for the right people or if it's the
wrong price or if you're making it too
difficult for people to buy or if
there's not a clear call to action i
mean these are kind of like obvious
sales 101 stuff but i just want to
mention them in case you're like i'm
doing all these things and it's still
not working well it might because take a
screenshot this it might be one of these
things um and then the other thing you
have to do so when i talked about the
basic understanding of instagram
these are the things you have to have in
place so just check these off
one by one and make sure you have them
in place number one you have to optimize
your bio i have to quickly glance at
your bio and if you write something like
i'm a unicorn mom who's got two kiddos
and loves to drink wine by 4 p.m every
day like
why do i need to follow you you know
what i mean like i need to understand in
your bio why i should be following you
so you have to optimize your bio that's
where you establish your credibility
that's where you help people understand
what you're good for then you have to
clearly state and promote your niche in
your feed
so pop quiz
can you go off niche in stories can you
talk about anything you want in stories
pop quiz
yes
but your content on your feed needs to
be niched the next thing is you have to
post niche content consistently
okay write this down because it's huge
the more you post the faster you'll grow
okay
now
if you don't have time to post two times
a day that's okay you can you can grow
slower if you have time to post three
times a day great you're going to grow
faster
my son is 24 years old and he
isn't married and doesn't have kids and
he runs you know a few different side
hustles
he's got time to post four times a day
his account has grown a hundred thousand
followers in just the last six months um
i post
once a day
on my personal account but i have 10
other instagram accounts that i've
outsourced to virtual assistants and in
those accounts we post three to four
times a day
my personal account you know
i'm already at 700 000 i've got these
other accounts that are monetized i have
fun with my personal account and i say
that so that you don't look at my
account say oh i need to do what she's
doing
do what i'm teaching you because what
i'm teaching you is what i do on my
monetized accounts okay but you've got
to post niche content consistently
content that people want to share and
then here's the other thing instagram
favors you when you use their latest
features if you're not using their
latest features
they they don't promote you because
you're not promoting their latest
features so you've got to use that
you've got to use the right hashtags in
the right spot now if you don't know how
to do these things i you know we've
already been on for an hour um i and i i
had to i just wanted to stick to the
selling but if that's something you
struggle with you're like i'm i'm newbie
to instagram and i really don't know how
to do these things please i beg of you
as an entrepreneur
to know where your gifts are and what
things you should do and what things you
should outsource i want you to outsource
your understanding of instagram to me
i want to share with you every because
this is what i'm obsessed with in case
you can't tell i have adhd and my hyper
focus
is instagram i'm obsessed with it and so
my son and i have created a course and i
just want to share this with you if if
you already have all these things in
place if you you know everything you see
on the screen if you already have those
then you know thank you for being here
with us i invite you to stay on for a q
a but i just want to quickly share this
um if for those of you like no i would
really love to know how to do all these
things and have you be my instagram
mentor we have a membership it's super
fun and it's where you start if you
don't have all these things in place and
you realize your time is better spent
elsewhere insta clubhub is it's a
premier instagram coaching membership to
help you grow
your instagram following but more
importantly so that it's with the right
kind of followers that convert to sales
um very quickly i'm just gonna share
with you really quick what this looks
like
it's five minute tutorials
and you basically log in you type in
what it is you need to learn like maybe
you're you've lost your music you're
like i don't have music or should i be a
creator or a business account um how do
i get the link sticker like all those
you can just type in that query and a
quick
five minute or less tutorial will show
up to show you how to do that uh the
training that i just did for you i did
do two of those a month
um it's got 24 7 q a which is great
because instagram has no support if you
have a problem there's nobody going to
help you
dozens of specialty trainings whether
you are somebody who sells a physical
product or you're in network marketing
all of the videos are simple screen
flows
and most i think probably the most
important training that we have in there
is how to find your niche we walk you
through that workshop style as well as
tips on how to go viral how to convert
your followers into customers it's an
amazing amazing underpriced value i
would say the number one mistake that we
made was
pricing it too low we priced it at 47 a
month which is insane i mean literally
if you think about that's kind of insane
i mean one live training i think is
worth well in excess of that you'll get
your money back in two seconds
if you apply what you learn of course
um but ultimately you save a ton of
money if you do the annual membership so
i always like to suggest that to people
too um if you can you know but again if
you want to just join for a month to see
if it's right for you and then cancel
you can do that too i don't care you can
join for a month and binge watch all the
content and then cancel that's fine if
it's not for you most people i shouldn't
say most
very few people
um
cancel their membership because they're
like holy cow
we kind of blow them away but it's all
these live trainings there you can see
them on the screen these are just some
of them there's hundreds and hundreds of
really quick
tutorials that was a key i was like i
want these to be super fast but we just
help you focus on the thing that you
need to do which is grow your business
again the annual membership is a
264 dollar saving
that's
a lot
so if you're like oh i know i'm going to
use it then do that but if you're like
i'm not sure then try the monthly
membership and like i said you can
cancel it at any time
um
here just i'm just going to fly through
these i'm sure you and we probably have
people on right now who are in insta
clubhub you can just ask them about
their experience their opinion matters
more than mine but these are just some
of our actual
students and the growth that they've had
again small accounts small accounts
right now are crushing
look at this her viral video went to 230
she's like oh my god she's not a small
account anymore she's huge now but these
are these are actual statistics from our
students
and um for those of you who do want to
take advantage of this i want to give
you an incentive for not thinking about
it
so it's what's called a fast-acting
bonus let me share this because we're
talking about sales today
let me just say this
if you don't give people
a reason right now to buy
then what we all do
is we go oh that's a good idea i'll do
that later and we don't and that's a
disservice to people because it's a pain
in my butt you've done this before where
you're like i want to buy where is the
link to that chair that i was looking at
i want to buy that chair where is it and
then you have to go back and try to find
it and then you go to the website and
it's sold out and it's a real
inconvenience so remember that you're
doing your customers a favor if you
incentivize them for taking action while
they want to do it i'm not trying to
talk into doing something you don't want
to do but i am trying to save you time
by saying okay just do this now so you
don't get distracted so you don't get a
text message so for all of you who have
something to sell remember
to incentivize people to do it now it's
what we call a fast acting bonus so your
fact-acting bonus for not thinking
further about insta clubhub is that i'm
going to give you the perfect post
checklist
that'll be yours i'll give you my 30 day
content calendar so you know like what
type of content to post you know to come
up with the ideas
related to your niche i'm going to give
you 50 instagram story ideas
and i'm going to obviously put you in
our private community that's our insta
clubhub you'll become a member of that
um and it's just an incredible
opportunity with no strings attached if
you don't like it cancel at any time
that's my promise to you
these are real results and um
it's uh something i'm very very
passionate about so now i want to just
take your oh it's risk free i think i
said that cancel at any time there we go
let me just fly through these really
quick because i do want to get to q and
a's for you but there's the there's the
link
best igtips.com
if you go there today you'll get those
bonuses those fact acting bonuses the 50
story templates you're also going to get
my 30 day content calendar you're going
to get the perfect checklist
and right when you log in you guys
there's a really simple
series of quick five-minute videos
they're going gonna bring you up to
speed like how to optimize your bio um
how to make sure you've got your like
you're just gonna run through those and
you're gonna be like set to start
selling and then all the like specialty
trainings like we update it every single
week this week we put in 10 new
tutorials
so there we go
um yeah we talk about that too nicola uh
about how to delete bulk delete all
every you can't there's not a question
you could ask that we don't cover in
instaclubhub so again join today go to
bestigtips.com
if you do so after today you won't get
that fast acting bonus but if you're if
you say you've watched this video watch
this training with sean and i just go to
bestigetips.com and i'll make sure that
you get those bonuses now let's get to
your q and a's let's you ask the
questions and and i'll do my best to
answer
chalene thank you so much for this
training and and
uh drop your aha moment in the comments
uh from this what are you gonna
implement what was your unlock or aha
moment there's so much value and you
know of course i focus on um
youtube so much as we do but this gets
me so fired up for instagram and of
course the growth there brock johnson
grows 100 000 followers
that's annoying that's crazy
and he's one of the trainers in there in
fact yeah you know check out our
archives uh on our think media podcast
we had brock on also sharing even more
value and i encourage you definitely uh
take advantage of best
igtips.com ck
antics was talking about i've been
implementing one tip at a time and right
now my focus has been reels i'm seeing
growth in just four
shorts weeks and she's been a member and
so um definitely check that out and
um we're gonna get into some q and a's
inside of our members only area um but
um let's just hit one question here on
youtube chalene uh what are your
thoughts on having certain content to
grow and content to retain do you see a
difference between trying to retain
followers versus attract new followers i
think you kind of have to do both right
like so so if you are producing the type
of content
that is just attracting people so for
example if i post a let's just say a
funny dance reel and it there's no point
to it and it goes viral and i get a ton
of followers um
to me i i'm not interested in being
popular so now i've got a bunch of
followers who aren't relate aren't
really interested in my niche or what it
is i have to offer
and so
to me that feels like a waste of time um
i i'm not a fan of creating content that
just gets you new followers they need to
be targeted if people aren't looking at
my bio and looking at my content and
saying to themselves this is valuable
then i don't want them to follow me
amazing well we're going to do some q a
with chalene in just a second but uh
we're going to
transition really quick hit the like
button if you're getting value and check
out show notes in the links down below
best igtips.com to be a part of
instaclubhub where you're not just going
to learn instagram best practices
but you also be learning the tips to
monetize to of course you know get an
roi on your investment this next decade
is the best decade to be a creator being
a content creator is the fastest growing
small business type so many different
ways and uh
what's amazing about chalene and she's
not just world class in her training but
she's also world-class as a human being
and always over delivers so check that
out as well as a couple other summaries
she had a book recommendation and um all
of those types of things and then now
we're going to be transitioning just
inside of our members area so thank you
think media podcast for being a part of
this training
and i will see you in the next
video